[Musique]
j'ai entendu maintes histoires sur ton
espace insulaire
tu es en mettant le fruit de la magie
on parcourt le continent
personne de ton ange ans si tu traque
les monstres pour de l'argent
je croyais que tuerait d'écrou des
cornes que sais-je
je les ai animé avec soin
toi aussi les gens disent que tuer un
monstre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi ne pas qu'ils se laverait deux
mois le monstre que je suis leurs yeux
chacun de nos choix nous rapproche de
notre destinée
s'il est toujours vivant il reste encore
de l'espoir
je suis à la recherche de cheratte de
ville
juge pas on dit que les sorceleur ne
ressentent aucune émotion quand quoi
crois-tu
qu'ils soient moindres
suprême
moyen
ils se valent tous
[Musique]
la princesse diana
tapez destinée
je ne peux pas la protéger
si tu fais fi du destin gerald
tragédie et cas où se décideront alors
toute l'humanité et ce par ta faute
je prends le risque
[Musique]